people ask me all the time how
do you memorize why do you do it
may god rest the soul of an old elder who
served in my church when i was a little boy
whenever that man stood in the pulpit
to preach he opened his bible as i do
but he never looked down he
always preached from his head
now here am i sitting in church little boy 13
short pants in my day you couldn't wear long
pants until you were old enough are you with me
you had rights of passage today every boy is a man
every girl is a woman in my day sure in my day
i can say it girls wore bows socks flat shoes
so a man would look a no that's a girl today
some men don't know who's a girl who's a woman
no no no i'm not joking now i don't support
pedophiles are you with me i don't whether it's
a male pedophile or a female pedophile but let
me tell you many men are confused is that a woman
or is that a 13 year old girl because they're
dressed the same way but anyway back then i'm
in my short pants i was a boy not a man
and i'm sitting watching this man preach
and he never knew it he died not
knowing the influence he had on me
influence and i said to myself in my 13
year old mind i would love to do that
and it stayed with me and it stayed with me and
when i travel now there are young boys i meet
who come to me what do you think
they say i would love to do that
what do you call that
god made two adults everyone else comes as
a child and much of what a child becomes
is the result of the influences that surround
that child counsels the parents teachers and
students page one or two paragraph two ella
white writes these words god holds everyone
for the influence that surrounds his soul
on his own account and on the account of
others in other words in the judgment you